I tell you what I've learned in dabbling
in deme in the different media is
writing a screenplay for an animated
film is one thing writing a scream leaf
or a live-action film is another thing
writing a screenplay for a video game is
fascinating and I'm great and the
disciplines are very different because
you're you're not only thinking about
language they're thinking about
immersion techniques if you would how
are you going to make the viewer or the
player the gamer immerse into the world
and as a writer of fiction that's again
almost a different set of rules in some
of these mediums the sort of
Aristotelian structure of free eggs or
you know beginning middle and end goes
away at certain points and I find that
truly thrilling but what has been great
for me in writing fiction is like a I
don't deal with notes from anyone I have
free rein over what characters do what
and the fate of the characters there's
no there's not such a thing as a down
ending in in writing fiction you know
you you can please the tale rather than
please the the demographics and the
quadrants of a movie but but I would say
the same can be done doing an
independent European or Mexican film you
have that freedom what is great here is
that you movie making the process of
making the movie goes against the
product they're like sculpting I think
Francis Coppola said is like sculpting
with sand in a sandstorm you know things
are flying away from your hands as
you're trying to shape the thing and I
agree I mean so the the process of the
moviemaking goes against the product and
at the end of the day you end up with a
movie that compromises it compromises
with the budget with the time with the
elements
there's no filmmaker that can have
absolute control unless you're making an
animated film
damn straight and instead of that in
fiction the moment you are writing the
scene is as good or as bad as you're
writing it it you can see the product
come to life and that's his final form
so it's very much like painting in that
or illustrating you depend on your
abilities but definitely the product is
part of the process in movies it isn't